[Music]
fifty years ago this month the crew of
Apollo 8 became the first humans to
orbit the moon just seven months and
three Apollo missions later Americans
would walk on the lunar surface
now nASA has announced a plan to return
to the moon and established a permanent
presence there this time by harnessing
the power of private enterprise on
Thursday the agency issued a list of
nine US companies now eligible to bid on
contracts that will enable the effort
here to discuss the project Plus this
week's nasa landing of a probe on Mars
is Time magazine at a dirt large Jeffrey
Kluger Jeffrey good morning good morning
let's start with this Thursday press
conference what exactly is NASA's battle
plan here the battle plan here is to do
four payloads on the lunar surface what
we've done for cargo delivery to
low-earth orbit which is to outsource it
to private companies in this case we
will be taking smaller payloads 1,100 to
2,200 pounds to the lunar surface
allowing private companies to do it with
a hope that this will lead to larger
ships and eventually to ones capable of
carrying humans it's worked more or less
in the low-earth orbit protocol what's
the less well the less is that were
three years behind getting astronauts
there and Boeing and SpaceX are
promising we're gonna try to do it by
2019 so the success has been uneven but
this could work keeping that in mind is
it a good idea to share this well it's a
good idea to share it for a couple of
reasons if it is monetizable and that's
a big if the private and private sector
brings enormous energy and enormous
innovation you saw with computers you
saw with commercial aviation if it's not
monetizable then it's left to NASA to
continue doing this and NASA is
decidedly a not for private enterprise
you touched a little bit on the reality
of it based on other things that have
happened previously but also how of our
interests in the moon changed well our
interests of the moon have changed in
that we're looking for ways to
commercialize it we're looking for ways
to monetize it in the past when
we went to - to the moon I always say
this we went to the moon for reasons
that cannot speak their name because we
didn't go for money we didn't go for
industry we went because it's just one
of those great transcended the next
Friday and I think that will always
endure because that's deeply in the
software that says they think that we
can achieve this again in ten years well
here's where I wish I was more optimists
a big sigh that's a bit yeah
in NASA we are always going back to the
moon we're always going to Mars we just
never get there I apply a rule when I
read a NASA press release that I call
count the conditionals more times they
say something should could or would
happen the less likely it is it's
actually going to happen so money was no
object back in the day that's right
clearly is the case right now I know the
US Geological Survey having a big part
in the training of some of these
astronauts what what's the science that
will come out of this do you think well
the science that will come out of it
first of all there are minerals that
could be used there are there are
resources on the moon that could be used
but the more we learn about the moon the
more we learn about the formation of all
bodies in all solar systems to rest real
planets gas planets moons moonlets it
also can provide us a place to test our
techniques for homesteading law
homesteading worlds and in on a much
long-term much more long-term basis if
we're testing it on the moon we're only
three days away from Earth if you're
testing on Mars you were eight months
away and speaking of Mars I'm sorry we
don't have time to get there we've got
to take a break but Geoffrey thank you
for the insight at least when it comes
to them thank you so much